por unos días angela en efecto en la
pandemia no detuvo a este grupo se habla
en este momento de más de tres mil
hondureños como bien lo decía ya se
encuentran en territorio guatemalteco
ningún tipo de medida de seguridad más
que portar su mascarilla ya que
irrumpieron en la zona fronteriza y pues
se introdujeron a territorio
guatemalteco una mala noticia es que las
últimas horas la cruz roja guatemalteca
publicó fotografías y confirmó la muerte
de un joven hondureño quien intentaba
subirse a un auto motor para así acortar
las distancias y falleció a raíz de los
golpes esta versión también no fue
confirmada aquí en honduras por la
vicecanciller de asuntos migratorios en
el y xerez a pesar de todas estas
adversidades no se detuvo esta caravana
y otra situación en contra que tendrán
es que se publicó también un comunicado
por parte de la casa del migrante en
guatemala anunciando que
esta oportunidad pues no se ofrecerá
ningún tipo de ayuda a los hondureños
como como ha sucedido en caravanas
anteriores dado que no tienen el espacio
suficiente a raíz del brote de la patria
también en este país centroamericanos
aquí en honduras se pronunció en su
cuenta de 'twitter' la embajada de eeuu
advirtiendo sobre los peligros que
enfrentarán estos hondureños en su
intento por llegar a la frontera méxico-
y cruzar hacia estados unidos de manera
ilegal